It's good.
Just try a bite.
Oh, this? You use it like this.
Hey, no messing around at the table.
Sorry.
This is not some scheme to poison me,
is it?
You don't have to eat it
if you don't want to.
When in Rome, do as the Romans do.
-Don't push yourself.
-Water?
"My. Such a strange flavor
but the spices and hidden sweetness
blend together in perfect harmony
inside my mouth."
"Oh! I can feel my body fill with energy!"
Yes, yes, yes!
That was "When the Samurai eats Curry."
Koharu!
Do you actually like it?
It seems like it.
What is that?
Hot spices. Would you like some?
There.
You put more on yours.
It's better for beginners
to start with this amount.
Your concern is unnecessary.
A true warrior fears nothing.
Don't say I didn't warn you.
Much gratitude.
-That's why I told you not to!
-Water! Water!
That wasn't so bad.
Look at your lips!
They're bright red!